c'était un fake c'est ton frère alan
qu'est ce que tu fais là
eh bien nous devions nous voir pour
préparer notre week end à san de palmas
tiens tiens steven qu'est ce que tu fais
là rien on discute
ah oui et vous discutiez de quoi des
pâtes des pâtes ya pas grand chose à
dire sur les pattes si je suis très
curieux de savoir ce que vous disiez un
sujet ta merde il a raison c'est nul
comme thème les pattes mais si je ne
trouve rien à dire de marans sur ce
thème
il faut comprendre que nous n'étions pas
du tout en train de discuter
[Musique]
au plaisir de vous voir monsieur podcast
ça fait longtemps
d'ailleurs j'ai croisé vos fils allan et
steven toujours en train de se tirer la
bourre
ils sont en tout cas en très bonne santé
ce qui n'est malheureusement pas votre
cas
m
alors vous disiez quoi suite disait
notamment que attend qu est ce que je
dis c'est déjà la fourchette très qui me
fourchette
il ne disait que ce qui est marrant avec
les pattes
[Musique]
en tant que proches incontesté de votre
famille je me dois de vous dire la
vérité à la vue de vos examens chez le
regret de vous annoncer que vous est
décédé monsieur podcast vous est décédé
la nouvelle doit être dur à encaisser
excusez moi je sais tout à fait normal
de prendre un peu de temps pour digérer
cette nouvelle monsieur podcast pendant
que j'y pense avant que la mort ne vous
rattrape
aviez vous choisi lequel de vos fils
allait reprendre l'entreprise familiale
[Musique]
monsieur podcast steven alan là je sais
dit rien une fois pour steven dit rien
deux fois pour alan dit rien trois fois
ci parle t cédé 17 et oui pardon jeu
depuis tout à l'heure je suis en train
de vous mettre la pression alors que
vous êtes dans l'incapacité de répondre
car vous est décédé j'espère que vous ne
m'en tiendrai pas rigueur
[Musique]
house est décédé pardon sera là là mais
ça ne veut pas rentrer c'est fou tout ce
à quoi je le notais parce que je sens
que ça va durer je sais pas combien de
temps je vais notées çà je suis désolé
ça me reprend 13 fois la matante c'est
noté je peux pas oublier mais je vous
parle encore des cd des cds décédé j'en
retiens pas qu'on attendait or la
boulette
en fait vous êtes vivant voilà j'ai
juste confondues les dossiers j'ai
confondu avec monsieur monsieur paul
proust monsieur podcast vous n'êtes pas
morts monsieur podcast tout va bien j'ai
juste et échanger les dossiers 7 sur wii
comme je le lis j'ai juste l'inversé les
dossiers
donc je me fais venir pour rien à la
bourde quand je pense que j'allais
prévenir vos trois fils je me serais
bien trouver comme un con mais trop
facile
[Musique]
bah alors vous avez oubliez tout ce que
vous avez dit je sais faire cuire des
pâtes al dente et faire jouer une femme
c'est pareil c'est un timing très
minutieux et à chaque fois je veux voir
bien jouer steve tu es le meilleur
est-ce pas car n 1 non c'est parce que
j'arrive à faire jouir une fois grand
max qu'est ce que tu viens de dire merde
quel con je suis pas sûr d'avoir tout
écouter mais il ya une chose que j'ai
retenu ce n'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois que vous avez fait des pâtes oui
voilà c'est ça on a fait une des pâtes
oui oui oui on a fait n'est pas cool une
quantité elles sont où je peux en avoir
[Musique]
oui vos trois fils steven alan et
prennent donne votre fils caché % jouer
systématiquement que j'ai un fils caché
moi j'oublie souvent qu alors j'ai honte
de le dire
le sellier a l'odeur de kaka qui est
d'en saper sa bombe à voile et voyons
aucune qui de alan ou de steven ou de
brandon reprendre à l'entreprise
familiale
vous le serez prochainement dans les
frères podcast est sûrement pas dans
l'épisode suivant mais bon lâché pince
[Musique]
macarons
pour s'abonner macarons
j'ai donc double
[Musique]